hello everyone i'm judge jeanine pirro
along with harold ford jr jesse waters
dana perrino and brian kilmeat it's five
o'clock in new york city and this is the
five
[Music]
biden desperate for a solution to
surging gas prices so now he's rolling
out a plan his old boss barack obama
once called a gimmick
joe biden calling on congress to suspend
the federal gas tax for three months but
has no plans to increase oil production
most experts say biden's plan will make
inflation worse and even some democrats
don't support it but apparently no one
told joe that
i'm calling on congress to suspend the
federal gas tax for the next 90 days
through the busy summer season busy
travel season to the companies running
gas stations
and setting those prices at the pump
this is a time of war
global peril ukraine
these are not normal times
bring down the price you are charging at
the pump to reflect the cost you are
paying for the product
do it now do it today
i'm doing my part
i want the congress the states and the
industry to do their part as well
biden also using this speech to bash his
usual suspects for soaring inflation
republicans and vladimir putin
i know my republican friends claim we're
not producing enough oil
and i'm limiting oil production
quite frankly that's nonsense for all
those republicans in congress
criticizing me today for high gas prices
in america
are you now saying we were wrong to
support ukraine
are you saying we were wrong to stand up
to putin
are you saying that we would rather have
lower gas prices in america and putin's
iron fist in europe
and after months of the white house
blaming putin biden getting humiliated
by his own fed chair on that talking
point would you say that the war in
ukraine is the primary driver of
inflation in america
no inflation was high before certainly
before the uh war in ukraine broke out
okay
all right jesse inflation was high
certainly before the war in ukraine
broke out that hurts and the republicans
should run that sound bite all up until
november biden knows he'll get primaried
if he unshackles the american dentistry
industry so he's tinkering around with
gimmicks and he's doing nothing about
supply we ran the numbers and over three
months this is going to save the average
american driver 17
i mean i'll take the savings but that
really really does absolutely nothing
the only thing that's going to bring
down gas prices you increase supply or
you have a recession and pal is doing a
great job of ushering in the recession
but until then you have to boost
supplies so he's traveling to the saudi
arabian kingdom and he's going to beg
the crown prince to boost production the
prince is going to say take a hike he
hates the president get in line and he's
gonna now not unleash american energy
he's saying he's not doing anything to
tamp down domestic production i have
headlines here it delays oil and gas
leases again cancels alaskan lease
cancels offshore leases in the gulf
wyoming new mexico texas colorado i mean
he cancels leases like dinner
reservations he doesn't think anything
of it refineries are at capacity they
can't do any more it's because we
haven't been allowed to build another
one since the 1970s and he's just
hitting these people with lawsuits and
regulations he should implore the jones
act pretend like we have a hurricane let
these refineries go at full throttle and
that's going to work i'm angry because
if you look at what he's done
he got in bed with china's biggest oil
and gas conglomerate and was taking
kickbacks from them that's the kind of
green he really cares about he doesn't
have solar panels in delaware his son
drives a porsche he drives a camaro he's
done everything he can to reduce
domestic energy production and
i just think there's no way this is
going anywhere you heard nancy say that
i don't know i think we're going to be
paying a lot you know brian he called on
the fossil fuel industry to drill more
oil and then he has the unmitigated gall
to call on the gas stations to lower the
prices essentially accusing them of
price gouging and if that were the case
i mean these are the mom and pop gas
stations get your department of justice
after them put your money where your
mouth is every time i walk in a gas
station i say look at these billionaires
i look at these billionaires ask me for
change of a 20 uh and the five hour
energy that they just uh just
actually gouging us it's unbelievable he
doesn't understand one thing is pretty
clear he doesn't admit what he doesn't
know he doesn't understand the oil and
gas industry uh and they
spelled it out for him but i thought was
so interesting and how they know you can
appreciate this the oil and gas industry
didn't get personal they got specific
they gave them some things that needed
to be done he said i know you called me
out so they said i want you to create a
tax credit for hydro hydrogen production
i want you to end permitting obstruction
on natural gas projects rescind steel
tariffs accelerate lng fix the
environmental rules and make them
simpler to handle and may give them a
timeline and when they can improve and
he came back and said oh i'm sorry i
hurt your feelings i thought what an
insult he didn't you didn't hurt their
feelings you didn't read their letter of
things that could be done so they could
actually get something done just real
quick about vladimir putin vladimir
putin is relishing the fact that we are
allowing him to be the hero who are
throttling the west with inflation and
high gas prices he is actually pushing
up the pressure and rallying his country
saying he is hurting the west just
listen to joe biden in order to help his
political fortunes in five months which
are doomed he is making vladimir putin
seem bigger than life there's no excuse
for that we are not in a time of war
right now this is not war he ended our
last war and humiliated us in the
process you know harold what's amazing
about it and he you know he in addition
to blaming everyone from putin to the
mom and pop gas stations he basically
says you americans you wanted us to
stand up for democracy and freedom you
wanted us to go to war in ukraine you
knew that that was going to affect
prices so it's our fault too i mean does
this guy have a clue
well i give him some credit for trying
what
well i'll give him some credit for
trying and and and i don't give him a
lot of credit but i give him some credit
he's not going to enjoy support amongst
democrats in the congress for the
speaker pelosi i think you you cited
rightly so
uh jesse is not in favor of this look
i've said all along i listened to his
national economic council director on
sunday i was on with him on fox news
sunday and he answered the question how
do you justify going to see the the the
prince of saudi arabia when you've said
these horrible things about him he said
when the nation's security interests are
at stake the president will visit with
people well our security is at stake and
we need to we need to not vilify u.s
companies but bring them into the room
energy companies oil companies alike
understand what it is they're doing uh
and how they can even be more helpful
and what support they may need to
brian's point around is certainly around
not just drilling but refining and for
that matter the other permitting they
need give them what they need i'm not
saying turn it all over
well i think we
that letter laid out what they wanted i
think you've got to do it you also have
to reverse the keystone pipeline
decision as much as some democrats don't
want to do that we are at a perilous
moment
in terms of not only gas prices fuel
prices until your point brian i think
something that's being overlooked putin
is certainly benefiting from this
politically and we shouldn't give him an
economic win as well if i have the
president that team i'd reassess it all
to put it all on the table and say to
our voters and supporters even those who
might primary him i've got to look out
for the interests of the country and put
that first and you know dana i mean with
putin the ruble is stronger than it's
ever been putin is sitting strong over
there in russia so putin is making fun
of us and in the end everything about
what what biden is doing
is not helping america it's helping
china
russia
and inflation and a bad economy remember
when he said that we'll wait a month and
see how the sanctions go and then but
now it's been several months and we know
how they're going they're not going fast
enough the other thing is that president
biden i understand that he brought nato
together great they're going to meet at
the end of the month but many other
countries are not fulfilling their
obligations to get the ukrainians the
weapons that they need so instead of
them helping them win quickly they're
allowing them to die slowly and that is
also an outrage so when he asks do you
say do you think that we shouldn't have
supported the ukrainians that nobody is
suggesting that and you can help the
ukrainians and open domestic on oil and
gas
on the communications front i usually
when you are going to roll out a policy
like this you've actually checked the
box with your own party and everybody's
in line nope not so much everybody on
the hill is like no we're not going to
do that for different reasons the
republicans have strong principles that
you know temporary tax policy is always
worse than permanent tax policy because
it just changes the way people work and
this would increase inflationary
pressure oh yes i mean but not very much
if you're only saving 17
the other thing i would say is the
administration is practicing a very
disgusting practice called policy
cannibalism
because the gas tax funds the
infrastructure bill the president wants
to hang his hat on the infrastructure
bill but now if you're going to take 10
billion or whatever it is from the
infrastructure bill now you've got the
national association of manufacturers
also many unions saying wait we're
supposed to get that money in order to
do our projects so it's um it's a big
gong show
moment for the biden administration
maybe they get credit for like trying to
come up with an idea but it lasted a
full 12 hours yep
and we were supposed to have a refinery
built in the virgin islands and it was
green lighted he could have done this
and not paid a political price and he
stopped it and no no more offshore
drilling wow i mean this is very obvious
amazing it is amazing
uh you got to watch
what his intent is i know what is this
intent i wish i knew harold
he's trying i mean again we i think i
think he should be doing more but i
don't i don't question the president's
patriotism i do question whether or not
we're going to get the results we want
look even wharton did an analysis and
they said you know that that this whole
thing it seems counter-intuitive but in
the end this gas tax holiday it's a
nightmare i went to brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now